You may recognize the song as All Star, for Smash Mouth
If you know it, something wonderful is about to happen
Although only musical notes are played
If you know the song, you'll hear the lead singer's voice
And the words of the singers.
I swear that what you hear is a digital piano sound 100%
It simply matches the frequency of the original song
It was not merged with real voices.
However, you can hear words.
This piano speaker shows a similar phenomenon.
It's hard to say what he's saying, but
Once the words appear on the screen, you will start to hear the speaker.
We emphasize
We all
Officials:
Educators
Two politicians
Social organizations
The essence of hearing is perception
After the acoustic wave reaches your ear, it turns into signals heading to your mind.
But your brain has a lot of external signals that it can not process at once
So context is used to formulate what you hear.
You hear the song's lyrics because the brain uses information it already owns
To understand the world.
That is why, if you have never heard the song, you will not understand what you hear.
But even without words, sometimes, we hear things that do not exist.
For example: jump tower.
About 20% of people will hear the sound of a jingle every time they land
A phenomenon known as 'audio response as a result of visual impact'
Do you hear him?
It is a kind of sensory accompaniment
Which occurs when the senses pass like hearing and sight in the brain.
Also, expectation plays a role here.
In a 2006 study, the participants' brains were medically painted
Who were told they would hear a voice
While they were expecting to hear something - without it happening -
The auditory cortex activated in the same way
As if you were actually listening to the sound.
So, do you hear it now?
Our brains are good at filling blanks
For example in this audio track.
Governors of the states meet with their own Legislative Council, which is held in the capital
Now, listen to him after the cough has been removed.
Governors of the states meet with their council .... which is held in the capital
Literally, there is a missing clip
With coughing, people tend to hear the whole word.
State governors meet with their own Legislative Council, which is held in the capital
This is known as 'temporal induction'.
Your brain complements information to understand the world.
Now, listen to this rhythm.
It seems to be getting faster, is not it?
It will appear to be growing faster forever, if you let it continue to play.
Which is known as 'carved rhythm'.
Where it starts to play relatively slowly and then accelerates
However, when the first one plays, the second one starts at half speed
They hurry together.
In the end, faster playing fades with slower music
The episode continues.
But your brain can not tell the difference
As a result, it sounds like it's speeding up forever.
You like to know the amazing and interesting things in the world?
In fact, we just started a new podcast called "Sidenote"
Where we explore things that hinder us
Or make us curious in life
Then we list all the amazing science that causes it.
We would like you to join it in iTunes, or any podcast application you use.
Your support means a lot to us on our journey towards exploring more science in the new media.
Again, the name of the podcast is "sidenote", and because it is new we are excited to know what you think.
We'll leave some links below
Subscribe to more weekly science videos every Thursday.
Translation: team translate @autrjim